I have been inspired more thematically
when it comes to the films that I have
made like for an example at the
Avalanche incident what kind of
questions does it raise and
as you said before I think it raises
question about gender and the roles that
we have in a couple relationship and I
think that human being loves looking at
monkeys because we are reflecting
ourselves in looking at them and we are
seeing someone that is close to
ourselves but we strip down the culture
and look at Christian more as a primate
a monkey that is uh with culture that is
trying to deal with life what are we
dealing with in which way are our movies
creating a behavior because movies
create Behavior art creates Behavior
everything creates Behavior basically I
think we can attack also our own world
we can then attack the cinema world and
ask ourselves questions of what we are
doing are we doing it out of ritual and
do we break through that convention and
do we actually say say something that is
important and interesting is this really
in contact with the world or are we just
playing roles you know the protagonist
is the hero and then the antagonist is
the bad guy and that is a very simple
way of explaining the world because uh
if we end up in a specific situation uh
where we don't know what to do then
we've suddenly become the bad guy
every time I make a film I want to
challenge myself
I I believe in this humanistic project
but when I'm pushed into a corner and I
end up in a dilemma and when I'm trying
to live up to my morale and my ethics
that's when it becomes interesting so I
wanted the main characters was to be
someone that believes in humanism and
believes in an equal society and at the
same time I wanted to challenge him and
putting him up to obstacles and and hard
situations when he doesn't know really
how to handle them as a human being
because I think that very often when we
are looking on how films are told we
have like a protagonist and an
antagonist you know the protagonist is
the hero and then the antagonist is the
bad guy and that is a very simple way of
explaining the world because uh if we
end up in in a specific situation uh
where we don't know what to do then
we've suddenly become the bad guy so I'm
trying to find out those those setups
that makes it possible even for me when
I'm sitting there and writing it that oh
my God I would also do this now and I
think it as as well that I think it's
very important that we directors and
people that are in the movie industry
are self-critical and we dare to look at
ourselves what are we dealing with in
which way are our movies creating a
behavior because movies create Behavior
art creates Behavior everything creates
Behavior basically and and and therefore
you also have to
uh dare to look critical on yourself in
the art
and in a movie when the sun is a monkey
appears in a an apartment and I think
that
I mean I I love monkeys
um and I think that human being loves
looking at monkeys because we are
reflecting ourselves in looking at them
and we are seeing someone that is close
to ourselves but we strip down the
culture we take away the culture and
suddenly we have the instincts and the
needs just exposed in front of us and
that's why I think human beings always
have been interested in monkeys and look
at Christian more as a primate a monkey
that is uh with culture that is trying
to deal with life and that is this like
sociological perspective that I like in
my films instead of building characters
around psycho psychological uh answers
you know or or how do you say character
answers that this person behaves like
this only because it's him
but this person behaves like this
because he's a human being and he's in
this position
and the setup around him makes it
possible for him to do these things but
I get him as myself you know you're
struggling with different kind of
situation when your morale is
questioned and trying to put Christian
in situations when they have to deal
with this on an everyday level as well
as a quite extreme level but I think
that the Consciousness and those
questions uh about morale and things
like that we always are having an inner
dialogue with ourselves in in in many
many many situations and sometimes we do
good and sometimes we do bad and
sometimes we don't know what to do
um and I think this is something that is
very specific with human beings that we
are super sensitive when we see
Injustice when we see an unbalance when
we see something that is unfair we get
very very provoked is that what inspired
the film in some sense it seems like you
like to write about a question and then
find the answer through the films I I
guess
um I have been inspired more
thematically when it comes to the films
that I have made like for an example of
the Avalanche incident what kind of
questions does it raise and uh as you
said before I think it raises question
about gender and the roles that we have
in a couple relationship and since I am
a man of course I'm I'm also using my
own life to try to tell the the movie
but
um
yeah so so more thematically I think
that I've inspired of of
sociological studies when it comes to
crisis situations like for example
um I read a study about airplane
hayekings and you can tell from this
study that the frequency of divorce is
extremely high after airplane hayekings
and it's some it says something of of
the expectations that we have on each
other when it comes to crisis situations
and that we are getting disappointed
that for example a husband doesn't act
like an action hero when it comes to
real life
I think that yeah we are working with
the visual medium and we're trying to
express ourselves in a spectacular way
so it's amusing to look at it and that
the images actually mean something that
we are trying to compose something that
and where the image in itself creates
thoughts and like uh like paintings or
thinking more like in in that way so
and I have been quite happy with like
yeah the scene in the trash I'm super
happy with and and the goal was for of
course to step up the film and make it a
little bit surreal and when you
sometimes find these real elements and
and play around with them and they
become very visual you know I've been
traveling around going to many museums
for contemporary art uh and did
something and an expression that's
called in the white cube when it comes
to Contemporary Art and everything you
know then you walk into a room and then
there's like a couple of piles of gravel
on the on the ground and then there's a
couple of mirrors and that is actually
what you what you meet when you go to
those museums so I think it made the art
pieces even more trivial uh so yeah
we're trying to attack that world a
little bit and make them ask questions
about what are we doing uh you know uh
uh yeah is this really in contact with
the world that is outside the walls of
the museum or are we just doing things
out of a routine and uh do we do we need
to question this convention on what we
are doing uh uh and I mean yeah so
like attack that and I think we can
attack also our own world we can then
attack the cinema world and ask
ourselves questions or what we are doing
are we doing it out of ritual and do we
break through that convention and do we
actually say something that is important
and interesting or are we just playing
roles oh and yeah what what do you hope
happens tomorrow I mean when you're
sitting in there do you do you like
watching it with an audience uh
but you're nervous of course uh as I
said I have done a lot of test screening
so I know quite much about how the
audience reacts to the film uh but I
hope for a good screening you know there
are good screenings and there are
screenings that are less good and uh an
audience that is
I want to create teams that is a little
bit dangerous you know so you don't know
where they are going so the orders have
to be a little bit insecure they have to
be on their toes because we don't know
if the film going to take us like so far
that we never expected it or in which
direction we are going I don't want the
audience to know that so it it have to
be a certain kind of tension in the in
the room where people are also feeling a
little bit afraid
uh so I hope that we get that like
presence of the audience so for writing
a square uh how many pages was the
script I don't remember that was it 124
or something like that I think yeah yeah
110 is not yeah I guess but I write in a
more literary way uh first so uh and
then I have someone doing an American
Standard script out of that uh the first
script that I'm writing but I like much
more to write part
in a literary way where you can write
where what the characters are thinking
and things like that things that is
quite hard to show uh when it comes to a
visual product but so I run in a kind of
different way and both of the scripts
that I've been doing actually have been
published as novels also the first major
and the square so I love to do casting
because I also use it as a part of the
writing process so what I do for example
one of the scenes is called the bills
and it's a man and a woman sitting at
the restaurant the bill comes on the
table who will pick it up and here we
have some gender expectations that the
man should pick it up
and I was trying out that I was playing
the female part sometimes and sometimes
I was playing the male part towards the
female actors and uh and and I did
improvisations around that setup and it
was so interesting to see what the
actors were adding and I think that
Shelby didn't was super in putting
pressure at me as a man making me feel
like you know I lost all my mail hood
and I think Harry stickinson in that
scene was um how do you say expressing
The Dilemma you feel as a man you want
to stand up for yourself you know but at
the same time you definitely don't want
to lose your male Hood so it's it's
something delicate and fun with that
situation that I used when I was doing
the casting and I was doing this in
Paris in Berlin in Stockholm in L.A in
in New York and it was from a culture
perspective as interesting to see how
they reacted differently a little bit in
in the different countries in the U.S as
a man to not pick up the bill that is
like you don't go there you know the the
men there had such a problem to deal
with that sin and not pick up the bill
and it was interesting because in France
I think it was two or the female actors
they said uh will I will make love to
you tonight why don't you pick it up so
it was so interesting how the currency
of sexuality and Beauty was in uh like
in a in a normal coupled relationship
situation what is the triangle of
sadness well the title actually comes
from a term in plastic surgery that is
like that you have a wrinkle in between
your eyebrows here and in Sweden it's
called trouble wrinkle so you have had a
lot of trouble in your life and that's
why you get this wrinkle but don't worry
you can fix it with botox in 15 minutes
and I thought it was like a funny
contradiction and like to fix your
surface and then feel better inside and
maybe it's true I don't know but that it
was like it's not a kind of dark humor
in it that I liked do you think
overconfidence is the mark of an amateur
uh uh no I think it can be good
sometimes you know that you're like come
on we're going to create something that
is historical we're going to make a
decision that is like really really good
that is a good uh ambition for me but
but but but you also have to allow
yourself to struggle with the scene
[Music]
be able to you know
dare to stay in that struggle